fog of love is like a loveless marriage
after 40 years
you're mean to be doing it with two
people but it's
a lot more fun with four
fog of love is a two player game about
building a relationship
you and your partner will each create a
character at the start of the game they
talk about it like a romantic comedy
you'll be given three secret character
traits that kind of tell you who you are
and kind of act like quests for the game
requiring you to have a certain number
of these really cute personality tokens
down in the right one of these six
personality dimensions
on a stunning and sleekly designed board
attributes like gentleness extroversion
or selfishness
for example this trait of you being
horrifically greedy here
requires you to have at least three
tokens in the downward space
of the sincerity attribute at the end of
the game to achieve it
in contrast this trait of you being
nurturing here requires you to have at
least
five tokens in the upward space of the
gentleness attribute
between the two of you you also have
this happiness card to measure how happy
you are
individually in this relationship and
fulfilling those character traits will
increase your happiness
at the end of the game because you stay
true to that greedy
and nurturing self that you are
lastly you each have these destiny cards
which are kind of like different goals
you
might have for the relationship and they
require tokens in certain personality
attributes
and certain happiness levels and you
choose one of these at the end of the
game
if you both pick cards that match like
being equal partners or
both staying together then it'll make
you both happier
the central mechanic of fog of love lies
in these scene cards which you draw and
play
throughout the game they give you a
simple story scenario that requires
either one
or both of you to make a decision
ranging from happy things like where
should we go for a picnic
the park or the beach to dramatic things
like were you flirting with sophie from
the office
me no what do you mean
i'm not flirting with sophie and a
beautiful wide
child bearing hips you will pick from a
series of answers on the card
a b c or d placing one of these four
beautiful and heavy tokens on the board
and revealing it and can i just say
these
tokens they feel so
nice it's like it's like really nice
dice that's what these feel like like
just going
ah that that is a nice
bit of design there your answers will
impact your happiness
your partner's happiness and where you
put those personality tokens down
helping you achieve those character
quests that you got at the start as well
as your destinies
but this is where it gets tricky
some decisions may fulfill your
character traits but
make your partner less happy or make
them happier but it would mean betraying
who you truly
are is it better for your partner to be
happy but for you to be living a lie
or for you to potentially be a little
too honest at points and
potentially hurt them there's even this
one scene where it asks you
do i look fat in this and you've got to
give your answer
and there's often an incentive to pick
the same answer as your partner adding
this extra
layer of complexity where you're trying
to figure out a compromise between
what you both want and what your partner
wants in the first place try and guess
that
as you place down personality tokens
you'll slowly be able to predict
which decisions your partner will make
and thus maximize both of your happiness
see unlike in other games the unique
skill in fog of love isn't in
good worker placement or in brilliant
resource management or in
cunning and strategy but in reading
understanding and anticipating your
partner
would my partner prefer cake or a child
the skill set makes it a really unique
setup for
a very different kind of game and it's a
really cool decision
and trade-off to force players to make
and it is genuinely exciting for you
both to
put down a secret answer in a scene and
then reveal it and
ah you both picked the same answer that
match like i want you to propose and
you want me to propose and you realize
how beautifully
compatible you are you're on the same
page and it's
also equally heartbreaking when
you know you you go into a scene and
then you you reveal the answers and it
doesn't match and it reveals just
how incompatible you are and that it
might
all be downhill from here you should
have stood up to him when he attacked me
like that but you're telling us that we
should just
ignore it and walk away yeah
there's a lot of moments like that and
eventually all of these scenes will add
up to some kind
of story and at the end of that story
you have to decide whether you want to
stick with your partner
or break their heart the greatest praise
that i can give
fogg of love is that it does feel like
an authentic simulator
for a relationship as far as a board
game can be
for weird and wonderful people
but don't be fooled by the soft azure
and rose colors your characters and
relationship can be of any sexuality or
gender you like
and that's really good and inclusive
this game is for everyone
and they have stories for disabled
people and other groups
see games like dominion can too often
lose their theme because it feels like
you're constantly
solving your own maths problem disguised
in medieval apparel but
[ __ ] of love just is simple and it never
really loses that magic theme that it
aims
to conjure to the maths and that's
pretty much it fog of love is
beautifully simple you can teach it in
like
five minutes and speaking of
teaching i do have to give its genius
tutorial system a mention
it teaches you through the game through
a deck of cards that
progressively introduce mechanics and
rules
as you play through that tutorial and
draw more cards
and what's even cooler is that the base
game even comes with some stories that
more experienced players can role play
through
but there is one big
problem with fog of love
it's just not that fun those decisions
and trade-offs are
really cool as an idea and though there
are moments which are
heartbreaking or really satisfying
for the large part they're not either in
the moment
or in the long run the mechanic just
doesn't hit that mark very often
even though you might have goals that
are at odds with one another fog of love
is not a competitive game and it doesn't
feel
good to achieve these goals that were at
odds with your partners
even if you have a goal to end the
relationship or
fulfill who you are but it's not
meant to be competitive so judging in
that way is kind of unfair except
it's also not really a cooperative game
either
because it's rarely clear what your
common goals
are or even if you share any major goals
in common
at all you're really quite beholden to
these cards that you adult
at the beginning of the game the sad
truth is that because of the randomness
of your traits
and these cards there are more scenes
where you make
non-decisions and give yourself tokens
that you don't need and
it's common to end up with an entire
hand of cards that
you don't want to play or just wouldn't
be fun to
and while those destiny cards that i
mentioned at the beginning of the game
which are kind of like your end goals
for the relationship you're a
love team or a unconditional love or
self-realization they're great as a
concept but
it too often feels like at the end of
the game you were just cornered into
picking
a certain one rather than feeling like
it's the result of the work and effort
you put into this relationship at the
end of the game
and speaking of games if you are looking
for a
game well it's kind of difficult to know
if you did
well in fog of love which is kind of a
big thing
at the end of the game we might both
choose to stay together
but we're both just kind of miserable or
maybe we break up but
only one of us is incredibly happy or
maybe you're both moderately happy but
neither of you
achieved any of your character traits
meaning you didn't stay to
who you are stay true to who you are is
that
good it doesn't always feel like you're
working together towards success it
feels more like you're
both compromising your own happiness to
achieve a
kind of equilibrium neither feeling
ecstatic to achieve personal goals like
your
traits but also not really that great to
achieve combined goals
either in other words getting good at
fog of love
i didn't feel was personally that
fulfilling
when things do go fantastically in the
relationship
it's often just because these goals that
you were given
at the start of the game happen to line
up pretty well
and not from meaningfully reading the
other person and anticipating their
wants
and needs and who they are and getting
to know them
as the designers probably intended see
the unfortunate trouble is that fog of
love rarely gives you that
wow we did so well moment where you both
made
smart critical thoughtful decisions and
got the results that you were wanting
and you would be forgiven for thinking
that a game like fog of love would
let you create an arc across the entire
story
that you slowly build up into a
heartbreaking or romantic
crescendo that pays off at the end
but that's just not really the case see
these scenes are so
disconnected from one another that it
doesn't really allow for that sort of
story
there is some vague structure to it
especially in those story packs that
they give you
in the game but it's pretty loose on the
whole
now to the designer's credit this does
fit thematically with what they were
going for
relationships relationships don't have
those gamifying moments of
crescendo and victory or anything like
that and
the endings of you know we broke up but
one of us is incredibly happy or
we're both moderately happy but we're
not staying true to who we are that's
kind of how relationships work they're
complicated
but that doesn't make it a good game but
tim you tell me
fog of love isn't meant to be about the
game about the strategy or the thinking
or the playing it's
meant to be about the role playing and
the characters and if you care about
them
then it's a good game right you're
caring about their story and who they
are and how they develop
well yeah that's that's the theory but
folk of love feels like it falls pretty
short in this regard as well
while you can play through stories you
know there's chapter one and chapter two
chapter three
four in the finale they only really give
a vague structure to how things work out
so
it doesn't give the narrative as strong
a through line as it
could and while you do create a
character at the start with a name
and traits and occupation and features
many of those things are either randomly
dealt to you or
out of your control entirely so they're
never really
your character which is really key to
caring about them
and their story these structures mean
that while role-playing is possible in
fog of love
it's never as enjoyable as it is in
games with either
more vivid and cohesive pre-made
characters
or ones that give you more creative
freedom with who you play
as fog of love is in this vein
very person-to-person dependent as to
whether the role-playing will be good
and thus whether you will enjoy fog of
love and i played this game with
role players people who like d d people
who play it consistently and
weekly and with that you may have a
consistently
immersive game and fog of love may be
great for you
but in my experience the stories that
you create with these characters that
you are given
ranges from well ah that was fun
too well that was boring
and for me that's just not enough
and ranging usually from 1.5 to 2
freaking hours i really need to be given
just a little bit more the beast
needs to be fed
but there is another but
a very very important but
said but a lot there is one giant caveat
to all of this
fog of love does as i've explained full
kind of flat as a
two-player game as it was designed
because the mechanics are either too
luck-based or inconsistent and
role-playing just
isn't that immersive but
fog of love can be fun can be immersive
can be
incredibly funny if
you're not playing to be good at it but
just make one another
laugh especially if you've got two or
even
four people controlling the same
character and and
and you've got these mix of
personalities as everyone kind of hashes
over
what the decisions would be it
can be fun if you embrace the randomness
of the characters that you're given at
the start and you're giving them strange
weird backstories just to get each other
laughing and
every every reveal becomes dramatic and
you play it up and
you might have fun playing fog of love
it's like how the real fun in pictionary
isn't
in winning isn't in drawing good
drawings it's always in the terrible
drawings
it's in going hey this is clearly a
donkey
it's clearly a donkey and everyone's it
look it looks like a ferris wheel it
looks like
i swear it's a fierce wheel and in that
vein fogger love simplicity really plays
to its strength it becomes a kind of fun
party game that you can break out when
you've got groups of people
around when you're tired or drinking and
you don't have the energy to bust out
scythe or spirit island it can be a
light-hearted game that you don't really
need to finish if you don't want to and
if you let go of that idea that
you can do badly at the game
will allow us to have a lot more fun now
i'm sure that there are people with whom
fog of love will really resonate that it
will be a game that they will love and
consistently
so and if that's you i envy you but
it's just not for me fog of love isn't a
game that i'll be busting out when i'm
looking for some role playing
and it won't be the one that i'll bring
out when i'm looking for a cooperative
game
and it won't be one that i bring out
when i'm looking for a diplomatic game
but it might be the one that i bring out
at 1am on a saturday morning
when i want to laugh about meredith the
professional lumberjack
who is okay who works all night
and works all day this is uh
fog of love stay nerdy and i'll see you
in the future